elon musk says
he would likely
vote for
ron desantis for president 2024 this is
an insider story by the way
musk was asked wednesday on twitter who
he was leaning towards voting as a
president and he responded the sentence
he made the comment after he was asked
if he would vote for republican for
president and he said tbd to be
determined or or to be decided uh he
added that he supported the democratic
candidate andrew yang in 2020 election
but believes desantis has a better
chance of winning in the upcoming
election musk said last month that he
would vote republican in an upcoming
election despite having voted for
democrats in the past years
and described himself as a moderate
neither republican nor democrat but
wednesday's tweet are his most explicit
political statement yet so jedediah when
you heard this what was your reaction
and were you surprised i was not
surprised okay at all uh my reaction was
great i think ron desantis is the i
don't know if he wants the job i don't
know if he wants to run he's the guy to
run he's 100 the guy to run
um it's unsurprising to me you know you
were talking before about you know biden
and obama
biden has you know multiple problems not
being coherent a lot of the times is one
of them i don't even think that's funny
i think it's a serious matter i think
people around him in his circle are
showing him an immense amount of
disrespect by letting him go out there
because oftentimes he doesn't make any
sense something's going on there i'm not
a doctor i can't say what it is
something's not right
um the other thing is is that the left
has gotten too extreme they have gone
off the cliff so when you talk about an
andrew yang when you talk about an obama
those were people that what was extreme
back then was conversations about
redistribution of wealth remember that
moment the joe the plumber moment we
were all like wow i can't believe that
was extreme
mandating that somebody should have to
have health insurance that was extreme
that was the whole debate about
obamacare can you force a 21 year old
who doesn't get sick a lot who doesn't
want to pay for health insurance to have
health insurance those were the
extremist points of view now look where
we're at it's gone completely mad
between the masking between the
lockdowns between all of these policies
mad absolutely mad so i think that the
people that were once democrats and were
once saying wait a minute i thought
democrats were supposed to stand for
freedom i thought democrats were
supposed to stand up to big corporations
i thought democrats would be the ones
leading the fight against big pharma i
thought they'd be the ones front and
center on that stuff they're not doing
their job according to a lot of those
people in the center now who lean left
those people are also not deaf dumb and
blind they own businesses they're seeing
what's happening they have kids they're
sending their kids to school they know
that what's being preached out there all
this woke ideology these are not
republican talking points and they know
that because their kids come home and
they see what their kids are learning
and their kids talk to them so this
stuff that's very extreme legitimately
extreme has gotten very real for these
people like a musk he's a very
successful businessman he is not a dumb
guy he knows that what's happening right
now is not good for the country so i
think you're going to see a lot of
people in his category i don't mean
financially in his category but i mean
people like that who are like i'm not a
committed republican but this is messed
up universally stepping out and they're
going to go the way of the desantis's
they're going to be able to vote in
these small local elections don't forget
your local elections those are the
powerful ones you change your community
at the local level first that's where
the big impact is then it shifts out
it's going to make a big difference so
i'm not surprised i'm very pleased to
hear it and i think you're going to hear
i think there are a lot of elon musk's
out there not finally not financially
although we all wish that was the case
hey i'll be an elon musk but um you know
when it comes to mindset 100 that is in
more places than we realize vinnie what
do you think i think he's
i think uh
he's right number one in that uh
uh but i think i don't think my mic is
on there's no it's something
okay sorry um i think dimasu i think
desantis is trump-ish if you think about
it just not as extreme he's always
cracking jokes he's always he's always
funny he's always like in the mix about
i mean there can remember we had his
press who was here pat that we
interviewed there's no way that he's
running is he 100 percent tina persha
yeah christina uh pusha yeah he's not
well she doesn't want to say that never
said it she never said yeah yeah if they
do go if they go at it like would that
they'd have to debate it's going to be
all right well stories are coming out
that he may run by the way this is what
desantis said when he saw the tweet yeah
i welcome support from african americans
funny like that's come on that's yeah
trump would trump wouldn't
be that clever but that is come on to be
clear a lot of people don't know that
elon musk was born in south africa
yeah some people like what is he talking
about there's there's some wittiness to
desantis on that one well here's what
i'll say as as much as jedediah doesn't
know about financial stuff she's very
well informed when it comes to political
stuff so respect to you i think the
reason why elon musk i'll put myself in
that category not the billions but as
far as like mindset goes where it's he's
come out he's never voted for republican
i think he said that he's never voted
for a republican i'm also in that camp
okay but we're at a point now where
we talked about on the on the last
podcast we're looking for some freaking
common sense at this point we're looking
for someone you know the joe biden was
supposed to be the uber driver to drive
us home because there's a drunk driver
at the wheel that was the whole premise
but it seems that the dementia is
affecting his driving so at this point
essentially america i think you know i'm
using elon musk
as a bellwether a canary in the coal
mine for america they're basically
saying
we don't need the orange bad guy anymore
we don't need the old creepy sleepy joe
guy can we just get a normal
[ __ ] who makes sense that
america will get behind and what i wish
for america we talked about as center
justice i hope and i pray that we have a
president that has 60
approval rating when's the last time we
had an american president who had 60
approval rating meaning it's not just 50
50 or 49 52 like when's the last time
that we've had 60
approval rating i think george w bush
had it when he came into office
that plummeted but i think what america
needs now is someone who just unifies
and says this guy's got common sense
yeah i've been a democrat my whole life
but i'm gonna vote for this guy yeah i'm
a typically republican and i'm i'm a
trump guy but i don't like what he's
done for the country
and i i'll vote for a descent like
desantis
i don't know if people want specifically
ron desantis or who he embodies i don't
know if that makes sense i'll tell you
what they want from this it's not about
desantis i do think he's funny and i do
think he knows when to get out of his
own way which is an art form in politics
because you can go too far and you turn
people off trump did that a few times
and i think he lost a lot of people
doing that when yeah a few no but a few
noted times where people are like okay
i'm out yeah um but like i have a
specific moment where i was like right
and many the david duke moment i was
like you don't know who david you can't
denounce the kick i was like i'm not i
think everyone has that everyone has
that moment and many people can point to
this moment with trump yeah desantis is
going to be harder and by the way
you bring up a very good point here
once you make that decision mentally i'm
out it's like if you're dating someone
and there's so there's something they do
you're like yeah yeah she snores yeah
yeah he's disgusting he smells you're
out yeah no matter what they do i don't
know but it's very hard to go back to
that i don't know about that i think
we're a very forgiving country
we we have such high expectation from
everybody that's on the big screen
but we're a forgiving country look how
many athletes with their past mistakes
that they made and how quickly we
forgave and we move on we are about
redemption i would love to see biden
redeem himself i'd love to see it what
are you talking about i got two and a
half more years to i'd love to see him
read him whether he's a one term or two
term i want to see him redeem himself
i'd love to see
uh trump redeem himself i'd love to see
any of these guys redeem themselves
if you if you go to a point that you're
out there's a difference between dating
uh where there's zero commitment versus
a guy that's now your president you want
to see that person redeem themselves if
you're running a company
almost every single one of your
employees
or the leader at the top is going to
make a mistake
there's there's not anybody that's not
going to screw up so some screw-ups are
small
some are mid-sized some are big and
you're going to have some tough
conversations with people and what do
you do do you automatically just jump to
conclusion and say i'm done with this
person no you give people chances to
redeem because then that person says
this guy is forgiven he's given me
chances but then there's a limit to
chances so maybe one two three four five
six okay then you gotta move on and say
this guy's just he's got a bad attitude
as long as for me if your attitude is
solid if you're working on yourself if
you're a team guy if your ego is
manageable if you're not defaming people
behind closed doors you're acting good
on the outside and then you we're gonna
make you work at the company and we'll
improve together right so for me this
whole concept of also expecting
perfection from all our presidents that
is so far behind me with clinton i'm
over to expect these guys to walk on
water that is not my standard my
standard is you screwed up you're going
to you're the president and we're going
to judge you this job sucks however a
thousand years from now they're not
going to write about the average person
in history books but they're going to
write about you so if you're part of the
history books and you're going to get
that kind of accolades you're going to
be on cover of all the magazines you're
going to write a book that's going to
sell millions of copies you're going to
put a tweet that millions of people are
going to follow there comes pressure so
can you please make some better choices
because we're relying on you to improve
yourself so i come from that thought
don't get me wrong both of these guys
have said a lot of crazy things but this
is america we believe in redemption i
like what you're saying i love the
message i love it
i have to go with adam on this one i
can't believe i'm about i'm about to
ruin my career by saying i'm just
agreeing with adam just so you know but
the thing about it is i think i would
love for a lot of people to have your
attitude i would love that because
that means that when you say i want joe
biden to come out of this and i want him
to do better you're rooting for your
country you're rooting it's beyond
politics for you it's beyond joe biden
it's it's not personal it's not personal
it's like i want the country to do well
i want him to come out of whatever's
going on and i want him to do better
that's that's a wonderful way to look at
it however i don't think that's the way
a lot of people look at it i think
people make a decision
people who can't stand trump
they will hate trump forever they
wouldn't no matter what the earth could
be caving in and jesus could come down
and say trump is the guy who's gonna
pull us back out and there would be
people who said i gotta sing so if you
like this clip and you wanna watch
another one click right here and if you
wanna watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]
you